IS
CAREUS DIES.
>> Reporter: THE "EXORCIST" ONE
OF THE SCARIEST AND HIGHEST
GROWSING FILMS OF ALL-TIME.
SPOILER ALERT --
IT ENDS IN THE EXORCISM OF A
DEMON AND THE FAMOUSLY STEEP
TUMBLING DEATH OF A PRIEST.
>> Reporter: AND NOW HERE AT THE
BOTTOM OF THESE ICONIC STEPS IN
GEORGETOWN, WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THE DIRECTOR OF THE "EXORCIST"
WILLIAM FRIEDKIN, WHAT IS IT
ABOUT THE FILM THAT HAS KEPT US
FASCINATED AND TERRIFIED THE
PAST YEARS?
ANY IDEA THIS WOULD BECOME SO
ICONIC AND DECADES LETT LATER TE
FILM STILL SO IMPORTANT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
YOU NEVER HAVE IN IDEA.
IT'S THE LUCK OF THE DRAW.
I ALWAYS FELT THESE STEPS WERE
THE METAPHOR FOR THE STORY OF A
THE FILM.
THE ASCENT FROM DARKNESS UP INTO
LIGHT.
>> Reporter: THIS PLAQUE IS A
RESIDENT OF WASHINGTON, D.C. AND
EVERY TIME I DRIVE BY, EVERY
TIME, I THINK ABOUT 'THE
EXORCIST" DOES IT MEAN ANYTHING
TO YOU?
>> I'LL TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT IT
MEANS, JAKE.
IT MEANS MORE TO ME THAN AN
ACADEMY AWARD.
>> Reporter: TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE WILL COME UP THESE
STEPS.
>> TENS OF ARE THOUSANDS WILL
SEE THEY'RE COMMEMORATED AS A
SCENE FROM A MOVIE THAT I MADE.
>> Reporter: EVEN DECADES LATER
WITH SO MANY CHANGES TO FILM AND
FILMS GOING SO MUCH MOREGRAPHIC,
IT'S STILL TERRIFYING.
JUST THAT LAST THREE MINUTES.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> IT CASS CWAS CONSTRUCTED THA
AND I APPROACHED IT SO THAT THE
FEAR SECTIONS WOULD GROW SLOWLY
AND THEN EXPLODE.
>> TAKE ME!
>> I DID NOT WANT TO SHOCK THE
AUDIENCE.
I WANTED TO PREPARE THEM FOR THE
INEVITABLE CONCLUSION THAT THIS
GIRL MIGHT BE POSSESSED BY A
DEMON.
THIS WAS BASED, OR INSPIRED BY
AN ACTUAL CASE.
THE FRONT PAGE OF "THE
WASHINGTON POST" IN 1949 FLATLY
STATED, THIS WAS A CASE OF
DEMONIC POSSESSION AND EXCESSER
SIEXCESSER
EXO
EXORCISM.
>> WE HAVE THE FOREMOST EXPERT
IN THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
AMERICA ON EXORCISM.
>> IN THE NAME OF THE FATHER!
>> HE'S THE GUY THAT TOOK ME
THROUGH ALL OF THE STEPS.
>> THE HOLY SPIRIT!
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THIS MOVIE
IS STILL PERSEVERING, STILL SO
ICONIC 40 YEARS LATER?
>> BECAUSE IT REFERS TO THESE
GREAT MYSTERIES.
EVEN IF SOMEONE IS AN ATHEIST,
THEY ARE CERTAINLY CURIOUS
ABOUT, IF ANYTHING HAPPENS AFTER
DEATH.
IT COMES DOWN TO, WHY DO BAD
THINGS HAPPEN TO GOOD PEOPLE?